welcome to this video helps playing
Dexter Dexter Morgan so have to be
cautious there as described but I
managed managed in recent games on
recent games i know in earlier games got
three out of three that seems good james
going for some early d for business can
i play with them oops 27 and Bishop 83 I
like this idea getting rid of his bishop
let's do that got a very annoying fly my
office when you take him to take care of
that that beast after this game
the trailer now not the trailer the
opening credits of textured isn't that
doesn't it have her fly no a mosquito
actually drawing blood to fire I
remember correctly so kind of fitting
okay I went back to see eight I didn't I
mean dtec c5 looked a bit tricky after
27 okay I can develop though not a big
deal i hope yeah but where is this
leading I don't really know I can take
you for here right don't i don't quite
get this where's this compensation for
the whole thing
I take you far it's got what Queenie 30
that's not really doing anything strange
check so if i take on g5 it's not not
helping i can just cancel though it's
nothing really wrong with that move
let's cancel i have 92 if I want all
night see to actually night situ was
just good look anywhere and then I take
III know Quinn's even Quincy 6 was good
maybe I should have done that but ok
that that's actually not really
important it's it's it's just just fine
as it is so Quincy 6i guess
intending to take the Queen and take
between maybe white I could have played
e6 actually winning the piece why didn't
I do that would have been nice it's most
not necessary okay what about now e six
wins the exchange almost but just almost
okay come on let's play very simple
chest I'm taking that and then playing
the excellent double rogan game I can go
f5 actually trying to trap this rook yes
20 g for then g4
it's not really necessary but I can't
prepare that maybe it's a nice little
trap f5 he has to move the rock now
the double rook endgame here is very
nice because first of all of course the
pawn I've got an extra porn but i also
have a great pawn structure no weakness
and it's got really nothing that he can
attack okay so he actually saw that but
i have e 5 right again threatening a CH
54 f 6 and the Lucas trapped Oh f6f 6
root G form let's do that it's kind of
fun
roop g4 and g5 g54 h5 next
yeah that was much easier than some
cement game winning the rook white
resigns yeah kh5 was possible that you
can first to rate the rook there I was a
very strange way of playing him so this
this I don't really don't really get the
compass even more merciless wants to go
f6 and then f5 yeah that that's better
but f6 is such an ugly move I didn't
consider it but it is strong yeah he has
to move it f5 and then i'm taking the
pawn next it's just it's just very good
for black yeah I didn't consider the
move but 95 is this yeah I don't know I
just I just wind up on down for Chad
compensation and I made some mistakes
actually hear hear night c 2 and now
this is just just totally stupid FC six
is a an immediate win ya can go here I
go a six somewhere here or here and then
it's all protected so I'm winning the
night on g5 so II six versions was much
stronger when the end game is excellent
but it's not it's not as convincing ah
here he five actually was was better
than what I did here would be five he
can continue but he had after this it's
over the look is trapped you don't get
it get it get it out anymore quite quite
neat yeah and no it gets easy here yeah
and then you can win the rook head will
with h5 just a funny funny trap of the
of this piece okay well thanks for
watching